[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo le magazine des temps
forts de l'assemblée nationale et du
sénat
avec à mes côtés kata gilder bonjour
katia rouges entament est notre invité
cette semaine et pierre dharréville
députés communistes des bouches du rhône
bonjour à vous bonjour est à la une du
parlement la décision historique le
conseil constitutionnel a ouvert la voie
à un référendum d'initiative partagée
sur la privatisation d'aéroports de
paris cette initiative est portée par
246 parlementaires d'opposition de
droite comme de gauche à l'assemblée et
au sénat la réforme de la fonction
publique le projet de loi va être
bientôt examiné en séance publique à
l'assemblée
parmi les points polémiques le recours
facilité aux contractuels discussions
sur fond de tensions avec les syndicats
unis et nombreux contres texte une
séance sous haute tension au palais du
luxembourg christophe castaner a essuyé
une salve de questions sur tous les
bancs de sénateur interrogée sans
ménagement sur la polémique autour de
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière
et puis on reviendra sur les deux ans
des manuels macron à l'elysée les
présidents des groupes politiques au
sénat on fait le bilan de l'action du
chef de l'état et des réformes engagées
depuis 2010 m c'est une première le
conseil constitutionnel a validé le
projet de soumettre à référendum la
session d'aéroports de paris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce référendum d'initiative partagée a
été demandée par 248 parlementaire d
opposition de droite comme de gauche qui
ont fait front commun pour contester la
privatisation da dp décidées par le
gouvernement
alice rougerie unis autour d'un manou
document la décision du conseil
constitutionnel qui valide le référendum
de la gauche à la droite en passant par
le centre les parlementaires de tous
bords savourent leur victoire n'a décidé
avec valérie rabault d'unir nos efforts
pour monter cette proposition de loi
référendaire ça a été une course de
vitesse je veux bien le reconnaître je
pense que c'est une grande victoire la
souveraineté populaire parce que
n'oublions pas que nous ici nous
représentons la souveraineté populaire
et je crois que c'est très bien elle
sait très bien manifester à travers
cette proposition de loi référendaire
mais la procédure n'est pas terminée il
faut maintenant recueillir le soutien de
10% des électeurs plus de 4 millions 700
mille voix
un site internet dédié sera mise en
place par le ministère de l'intérieur
nous donnons les clés pour cette
deuxième phase à nos concitoyens en leur
disant vous avez la possibilité c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de la
république que vous avez la possibilité
qui vous est donnée par une démarche des
parlementaires de dire de vous exprimer
de dire que vous ne voulez pas la
privatisation d'aéroports de paris lancé
par l'exécutif voté par le parlement
la privatisation est reportée le temps
de la procédure a un revers pour la
majorité qui dénonce un affaiblissement
des institutions pour moi on gagnera à
développer la démocratie directe
si elle vient compléter la démocratie
parlementaire si elle affaiblit la
démocratie parlementaire
personne ne gagnera le recueil des
signatures durera neuf mois sous
contrôle du conseil constitutionnel
pierre dharréville et bien le conseil
constitutionnel on l'a vu a donc validé
l'idée est bien d'un vote de soumettre
au vote la privatisation d'aéroports de
paris
est ce que c'est pour vous une grande
satisfaction ah oui c'est une très très
bonne nouvelle je suis naturellement
signataires 1 2
cette demande de référendum d'initiative
partagée et je crois que c'est un outil
qu'il était utile de mobiliser sur ce
sujet on aurait pu le mettre derrière le
mobiliser sur première mais oui c'est
une première donc oui je crois que en
tout cas le sujet d'aéroports de paris
était suffisamment un crucial pour que
des parlementaires de différentes
familles politiques puissent s'unir et
permettent que ce référendum
d'initiative populaire ait lieu donc
voilà je me félicite effectivement que
le conseil constitutionnel et validés
mais maintenant tout reste à faire alors
justement est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est pas un peu mission impossible
quand on voit tout le parcours qui reste
pour éventuellement se grippe comme on
l'appelle aboutisse un jour le
référendum d'initiative partagée on se
demande s'il a été fait pour être
vraiment mobilisables si c'était pas un
un petit gadget qui a été instauré dans
la constitution pour faire un peu
semblant boncourt ça devait bien se
l'avouer cela étant dit nous avons
réussi à passer le premier obstacle et
nous allons nous battre pour passer le
deuxième il faut mobiliser toile
deuxième ces quatre millions sept cent
dix sept mille signatures a fait des
pressions de corps électoral qui font
ces gens qui ont leur carte électorale
les quinze jours qui devront
effectivement signé pour dire je
souhaite qu'il ait un référendum sur ce
sujet ça c'est faisable pour vous je
pense que c'est à portée de la main mais
il faut une bataille pour cela et donc
nous allons nous engager en tout cas moi
je vais m'engager fortement pour que
celles et ceux qui souhaitent se réfère
un homme et dieu puisse se manifester et
j'espère que le gouvernement jouera
pleinement le jeu qui mettra à
disposition les outils dont il est fait
état dans la constitution de manière
opérationnelle verront pas le débat bien
sûr quels sont pour vous et bien
justement les priorités pour simplifier
et le rip puisqu'on a dit c'est une
première vous découvrez toutes les
difficultés de cette procédure
on voit bien d'abord il faut un nombre
de parlementaires conséquent pour que la
procédure puisse être déclenchée nous
n'avons pu par exemple si nous avions
voulu le faire simplement avec les
groupes de gauche
c'était impossible si on voulait rester
sur cette formule mais en vérité c'était
un faire un dom d'initiative
parlementaire avec un soutien populaire
plus que partagés voyez c'est une
formule assez hybride
ça n'est pas le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne tels que nous avons eues
l'imaginer le portait déjà à l'époque
mais vous dites il faut une bataille
politique alors on voit ces députés de
d'opposition de droite comme de gauche
qui sont qui se sont unis dont vous êtes
pour porter ce rythme et le faire
aboutir en tout cas pour obtenir le feu
vert du conseil constitutionnel
est-ce que ce set ce front politique là
perdurer ce que vous dites vous êtes
prêt à mener la bataille politique mais
avec vos collègues de droite et c'est
une très bonne question parce qu'il y a
sans doute des motivations différentes
qui nous conduisent à vouloir parfois
similaires mais parfois très différentes
qui nous conduisent à ne pas vouloir de
la privatiser vous reteniez quand même
une question d'intérêt général
voilà et je crois que c'est cette
question de l'intérêt oui général oui
parce que outre la privatisation des dp
bien sûr sa part une aberration c'est à
part une aberration pour de très très
nombreux députés
cela étant dit dans le débat qui s'ouvre
il ya deux questions la première c'est
de savoir ce que nous voulons pas un
référendum et je pense qu'ils y compris
des gens qui pourraient éventuellement
être favorable aéroports de paris et
vous pourrez signer pour dire oui bien
sûr faisons un référendum
bon deuxième chose c'est faut-il ou pas
privatisée et là moi je constate que
dans le projet de loi pacte qui contient
cette privatisation des aéroports de
paris il yad'autres privatisation il y a
une fille il ya la française des jeux
et moi je n'ose pas le mois dont on
parle tant par le mois et qui nous font
pas l'objet de ce référendum
d'initiative partagée et moi je pose
effectivement la question plus largement
de la capacité d'action de la puissance
publique de la propriété publique d'un
certain nombre de choses pour garantir
des biens communs pour garantir des
droits fondamentaux
c'est une question fondamentale qui nous
est posée et avec un report de paris je
crois qu'on est au coeur du sujet à bien
la révéler ce que c'est maintenant le
début de neuf mois de campagne pour ou
anti macron jusqu'ici bien le référendum
anti adp avait été portée notamment de
façon puissante dans les rangs des gilet
jaune
comment est ce que vous vous allez à
mener campagne dans les prochains mois
et la campagne elle est sur un sujet
concret sur lequel il doit y avoir débat
moi je suis pour que le débat politique
se déploient pleinement et que nous
fassions des choix démocratiques en
pleine conscience donc une dimension
politique si ça va être courant contre
le chef de l'état
non je crois que c'est d'abord cette
mesure là qui est qui est visé après est
évidemment la manière dont emmanuel
macron assumera cette décision et la
défendre à elle aura des conséquences
mais c'est pas une opération
politicienne je pense que c'est vraiment
une question
mental sur laquelle nous avons souhaité
que notre peuple puisse avoir le dernier
mot et se prononcer il y en aurait je
crois beaucoup d'autres mais au moins
c'est là sur la table alors on va parler
pierre dharréville d'un dossier que vous
suivait de très près la réforme de la
fonction publique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le texte arrive en séance publique dans
l'hémicycle la question du recours aux
contractuels que le texte prévoit de
généraliser à marquer lé débat en
commission je vous propose d'écouter cet
extrait ce que pense une go bernalicis
de cette question des contractuels
votre collègue députée de la france a
soumis ce qui n'a pas hésité à mettre
les pieds dans le plat et le traiteur
pourquoi précisément les emplois de
direction
vraiment je le redis c'est c'est
clairement la volonté du président de la
république du candidat emmanuel macron
de faire le ménage au sein de
l'administration notamment la nutrition
d'état et les administrations centrales
pour avoir des gens qui soient
complètement l'ohio l'ohio sens
politique du terme et pas administratif
est vraiment qu'ils soient des
serviteurs zélés de la politique du
gouvernement
s'écartant de la même peut-être d'un
certaine forme de libre arbitre qui
pourrait leur être salutaire et qui est
pour pour le pour le coup garantie bien
plus par par le statut donc vraiment au
final le sidibé est ce que ce serait pas
pour quand même positionné à des postes
à responsabilités un certain nombre de
copains qui gravite aujourd'hui dans des
grandes entreprises ti vct je sais pas
moi vinci bouygues total sanofi enfin
tous ceux qui ont financé la campagne du
président de la république en fait
qu'avant la ville est ce que comme votre
collègue de la france un service vous
dénoncez ce recours massif aux
contractuels qui viendrait prendre les
postes de direction ou alors est-ce que
c'est exagéré
oui bien sûr je le dénonce fortement
fermement j'ai écrit une lettre ouverte
sur ce sujet il ya quelques jours parce
que je pense que la réforme de la
fonction publique elle ne concerne pas
simplement les agents elle nous concerne
toutes et tous la fonction publique
c'est l'outil d'une république sociale
c'est notre bien commun elle doit nous
permettre de relever les défis du
quotidien les défis de l'avenir
et c'est pour ça que la fonction
publique exister pour ça qu'il existe un
statut de la fonction publique ce texte
menace ce statut oui ce texte attaque ce
statut frontalement parce qu'il est dans
une logique de privatisation de
confusion qui était évoquée par ugo
bernalicis à l'instant de fragilisation
également de la fonction publique on
veut faire finalement
des instances de l'état une sorte de
passe-plat du marché et avec un
affaiblissement de la capacité directe
d'intervention et d'action de l'état de
l'indépendance y compris des des agents
parce que le statut c'est pas le statut
des agences et le statut de la fonction
publique faire sa garantie véritablement
que lorsqu'on y travaillent
eh bien d'abord en d'aucun service et
puis ensuite voilà il ya des sa porte
des garanties à l'ensemble de la
communauté nationale et secrétaire
d'état olivier dussault estime que cette
réforme est attendue par les agents qui
veulent de la mobilité accéder à la
formation ou encore maîtriser leur
carrière est ce que vous entendez ces
arguments est ce que pour vous il sont
justes mais obligé du soft il faut
qu'ils regardent ce qui se passe dans le
pays
parce que là on continue quand même
d'être dans des attitudes qui sont
profondément étonnante l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales de la fonction
publique étaient mobilisés cette semaine
dans la réalité c'était une idée ce jet
d'eau sur unis pour contester ce projet
bon donc il faut écouter ce que disent
les agents véritablement elles peuvent
parler à leur place en faisant semblant
où l'exécutif est sourd à ces ce message
touche pas à mon cerveau l'examen à
décider d'un choix profonde profondément
libérale ils veulent appliquer et
ensuite il est ce qui passe en quarts
semblant que tout se passe bien que ya
la concertation mais on connaît ce que
ça veut dire
quinze mois de concertation six semaines
de consultations officielles pour vous
n'y a pas eu de réel dialogue malgré
cela le syndicat compte l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales expliquent ne
sont pas contentés que ça ne va pas donc
ça veut dire qu'il n'ya pas une
véritable concertation on les a fait
parler et ensuite le projet de loi a été
mis sur la table tel qu'il avait été
imaginé dès le départ et donc si on veut
agir pour répondre aux aspirations des
agents sur les évolutions de carrière
sur un certain nombre de succès sur le
traitement des fonctionnaires leurs
salaires
eh bien je crois qu'il ya des mesures à
prendre mais il n'y a pas besoin de
casser la fonction publique pour ça
justement que cette réforme est examiné
en première lecture à l'assemblée
elle ira ensuite devant les sénateurs le
gouvernement souhaite aller vite
il a évoqué un jour il a dit que le
calendrier c'était que ce soit adopté
avant l'été
est-ce que vous pensez que ce sera tenu
ou est-ce que vous allez vous battre
pour faire durer le débat parlementaire
moi je suis jamais dans les
des attitudes bataille de ce type
l'objet nous allons nous battre
pas pour faire durer sur le front mais
nous allons nous battre le font bien sûr
parce que y compris le débat qui a lieu
ici c'est un débat qui qui est en train
de monter dans le pays et il faut que ce
débat prenne de l'ampleur
et donc je crois que la bataille que
nous allons mener elle va viser à
obliger le gouvernement à se justifier à
mettre sur la table des contre
propositions a contesté la philosophie
de ce projet de loi et essayer de le
faire reculer
donc oui nous allons mener bataille dans
cette optique là parce que nous pensons
que c'est grave ce qui est dans
l'hémicycle dans la rue dans
circonscription partout oui tous ces
objets par exemple dans la
circonscription j'ai tenus il ya dix
jours et réunion publique sur le sujet
et les bouches du rhône
vous n'êtes pas rassurés par le fait qu
emmanuel macron a dit que la suppression
de 120 mille fonctionnaires n'était plus
un totem ce qu'il a dit le 25 avril mais
pour l'instant je n'ai pas vu
d'engagements précis sur le sujet et ils
ont affiché un objectif qui était de
supprimer 120 mille postes de
fonctionnaires donc il va nous dire bon
on va peut-être en supprimer un peu
moins mais où est là où est la victoire
au bout du compte tout
donc voilà on reste dans cette
philosophie dans cette logique qui vise
à tailler la fonction publique il ya pas
pour moi pas de nouveautés pour
l'instant pierre dharréville également
cette semaine et bien la séance de
questions d'actualité au sénat a été
tendu christophe castaner a dû faire
face au tir croisé des sénateurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
place de la contrescarpe en 2018 pitié
salpêtrière en 2019
le ministre de l'intérieur était au
coeur de la polémique au sénat il avait
qualifié dans un premier temps aux
d'attac l'intrusion qui s'est déroulé la
semaine dernière dans l'hôpital parisien
extraits on a attaqué un hôpital on a
agressé son personnel soignant c'est
unir une intrusion violente
avez-vous dit successivement monsieur le
ministre c'est une exactions
inqualifiables et indigne d'après la
ministre de la santé
alors monsieur le ministre sur quels
faits le gouvernement s'est-il fondé
pour donner l'alarmé ou français sur des
violences qui n'ont pas eu lieu
les responsables hospitaliers qui m'ont
accueilli m'ont fait part de leur
émotion
et c'est sur la base de leurs émotions
qui d'ailleurs était filmé par les
chaînes d'information que je me suis
prononcé et c'est sur la base de cette
émotion extrêmement forte que j'ai
dénoncé ces faits raison pour laquelle
j'ai utilisé ce mot qui au vu des
événements le lendemain mais surtout au
vu de la polémique qui ont été menées et
qui mettait du coup en cause la qualité
exceptionnelle du travail des forces de
sécurité j'ai souhaité faire évoluer le
mot en prenant celui de la directrice et
donc d'évoquer une intrusion pouvez-vous
enfin reconnaître qu émettre des
mensonges ou des contre vérités
même si on modifie son propos
ultérieurement pour salir le mouvement
social lorsqu'on est ministre relève du
scandaleux et de l'inacceptable la
crédibilité du miz de l'intérieur qui a
manipulé l'opinion est aujourd'hui
entaché pour le moins il devrait être
entendu par les commissions des lois du
parlement
avoir un mot qui n'est pas adaptée quand
on est un responsable public ça arrive
c'est courant ça m'est arrivé est
peut-être un jour cela vous arrivera
t'il le corriger le corriger en assumant
d'avoir utilisé un terme qui n'était pas
adapté et en revenant un terme qu'il est
parfaitement fait honneur à celui qui le
fait est une bonne chose et me semble à
la hauteur de ce que doit faire un
responsable politique et je veux à cette
occasion redire toute ma confiance pour
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur je
vous remercie le ministre de
haier est revenu sur ces mots il a
reconnu qu'il n'aurait pas dû employer
le terme d' attaque à ce qu'il doit
encore être auditionné pour vous par les
parlementaires sur cet épisode
oui parce que il y à des faits qui se
sont produits à nouveau lors de cette
manifestation du 1er mai qui mérite
d'être étudiée avec des ados de la pitié
salpêtrière sûr parce que les
témoignages qui ont été portés à notre
connaissance depuis et bien interroge
quand même sur l'attitude qui a été
celle choisie par le gouvernement face à
cette manifestation donc on a à chaque
fois finalement la latitude de plaisir
face aux syndicats notamment de
violences il ya une volonté finalement
de produire un récit gouvernementale un
récit fantastique un récit homérique
jupitérien lequel précise et celui
d'expliquer finalement il ya le gentil
gouvernement d'un côté et les méchants
manifestants de l'autre et de produire
quand même une forme de réponse
répressive face à ce mouvement qui se
perpétue de manifestation en
manifestation et donc je crois qu'il dit
a besoin d'eux donc j'ai la tension qui
seraient mises en jeu sur serait
orchestré vous n'êtes pas les objectifs
hab volontairement oui une stratégie de
tension avec une tentative de
manipulation de des faits ou de
grossissement des faits loupe sur sur
les événements qui se sont produits pour
ne pas parler du fond une passerelle du
sujet pour ne pas parler des
revendications pour écarter balayé d'un
revers de main la contestation profonde
qui existe dans le pays
politique vous ne pensez pas que
christophe castaner a pu aussi être
simplement mal informé le mercredi où il
a eu à ces propos ce que je constate
c'est que ce qui s'est produit
auparavant c'était une stratégie de
tension et ce qui s'est produit pendant
et après c'était une stratégie de
tension et donc je crois qu'il ya une
véritablement une volonté du
gouvernement la d2 produire ce récit
dont je parlais et que nous devons
interroger la réalité de ce qui s'est
passé
et quelle a été l'attitude
les ordres les consignes qui ont été
données la politique choisie par le
gouvernement
justement il ya une enquête en cours sur
ces faits là sur ce qui se serait passé
ou pas il ya aussi cette demande de
commission d'enquêté parlementaire
en quoi cette commission enquête
parlementaire si elle se met sur en
place serait utile
ça fait un an maintenant que nous avons
proposé déjà une commission d' enquête
sur les faits qui se sont déroulés le
1er mai dernier puisqu'il ya déjà eu une
difficulté de manifester ce jour-là nous
avons réitéré cette demande il ya
quelques semaines quelques mois de cela
à l'occasion d'autres événements graves
qui se sont produits et nous
recommençons à demander cette commission
denquête parce que nous pensons que le
parlement doit contrôler l'action du
gouvernement y compris en matière de
maintien de l'ordre et de garantie de la
liberté constitutionnelle fondamental de
manifester très rapidement est ce que
pour vous cet épisode de nous faire
réfléchir à la question de l'emballement
médiatique de la manipulation de
l'information les faits que news quand
on voit comment de nombreux médias aussi
ont relayé bien cette théorie de la tacc
toujours il faut toujours réfléchir à la
manière dont nous nous informons dont
nous informons également
cela étant dit je crois que les médias
dans cette affaire ont aussi rapidement
et sans doute au fait marche arrière
rapidement si grâce aux réseaux sociaux
fait une partie des médias sans doute
tous n'ont ils pas eu la même la même
attitude mais a rapidement il ya eu des
contres éléments qui ont été apportées
face aux affirmations du ministre qui
ont obligé d'ailleurs à ce recul alors
il y a deux ans et bien emmanuel macron
et est élu président de la république
chamboulant le paysage politique et
c'est l'occasion d'un petit bilan pour
les sénateurs et après des débuts
jupitérien et des réformes menées
tambour battant et vient l'heure est à
la crise des gilet jaune est à la
recherche d'un nouveau souffle pour
l'exécutif
que pensent les sénateurs de ce début de
mandat jonathan du prix yeahs leur a
demandé seul sur fond de dallas joie
emmanuel macron traverse la cour du
louvre le 7 mai 2017
l'ancien ministre de l'économie est élu
à 39 ans plus jeune président de la
république française
le mois suivant emmanuel macron remporte
une large majorité aux législatives et
mettent en place ces réformes ordonnance
travail réforme ferroviaire ou encore
loi élan à un rythme effréné
beaucoup de français pouvaient souscrire
à cette ambition réformatrice
force est de constater qu elle s'est
heurtée à la méthode qu'il a employés
c'est à dire la verticalité l'absence de
concertation et de prise en
considération de
ce qu'on appelle les corps
intermédiaires les premiers temps il
jouit d'un contexte favorable
emmanuel macron et crédible sur le plan
européen et international paris remporte
les jeux olympiques de 2024
les bleus la coupe du monde mais la
sphère benalla vient gripper la machine
présidentielle à l'été 2010 8
je prends une affaire banale à pour ce
qu'elle est une affaire personnelle une
dérive personnelle grave
par ailleurs mais qui n'entache en rien
la politique globale du gouvernement par
ailleurs les réformes sont à l'arrêt des
ministres de premier plan comme gérard
collomb nicolas hulot démissionne mais
le tournant s'opère à l'automne 2010 8
l'augmentation annoncée des prix du
carburant révolte une partie de
l'opinion
la crise des gilet jaune éclate pour
versailles 2018
le vote d'un maquereau avait commencé
son propos rappelez-vous par an je sais
aussi douté je sais que tout ne va pas
bien et cetera et cetera
et puis on a eu la clé gilet jaune ce
qui signifie qu'il ya un décalage entre
les propos et la réalité des faits est
ressentie par les français pour sortir
de la crise il prend des mesures en
faveur du pouvoir d'achat 10 milliards
d'euros sur la table et lance le grand
débat mais sa restitution ne convainc
pas pour l'opposition les maux du pays
sont toujours en suspens mails mâcon a
voulu sortir du clivage droite gauche
mais il a si j'ose dire revitaliser un
clivage beaucoup plus conflictuel entre
le haut et le bas entre le peuple et les
élites et et ça c'est hautement
conflictuelle al'approche des
européennes
emmanuel macron mise sur le scrutin pour
reprendre la légitimité que la rue lui
conteste les faits voilà alors réformes
tous azimuts depuis deux ans cotisations
chômage maladie réforme de la sncf
parcours sur ordonnance sur le code du
travail suppression de liesse si vous
deviez retenir une de ces réformes
une bonne réforme tient peu difficile
est-ce que vous en 6-1
il y en a peu dans les réformes qui me
viennent à l'esprit ce sont de mauvaises
réformes de très mauvaises réformes
donc pour vous le bilan est globalement
négatif à résidence et c'est un bilan
oui c'est deux ans de trop d'emmanuel
macro on sait ces deux ans de casse
sociale de violences sociales restant
ces deux ans de politique du président
des riches ces deux ans de narcissisme
au plus haut sommet de l'état
voilà non je considère qu'on est
vraiment dans le
il a engagé une politique de grand
chamboule tout la république qui a pas
une seule bonne réforme une des enfants
qui trouvent grâce à rosières n'a peu il
ya déjà il ya des mesures que parfois
nous avons voté parce qu'il ya pas de
raison quand il mesure est bonne que
nous ne l'avions pas mais quand on
regarde ce qui a été fait ce qui était
produit par ce gouvernement
ce sont des choix politiques
profondément régressif profondément
libéraux profondément de droite et des
clients toujours conforté les mêmes
c'est à dire les plus puissants les
grands propriétaires de notre pays je
parle des grands actionnaires des
banquiers etc voilà tous les actes qui
ont été produits on se sont inscrits en
tout cas dans cette logique après il ya
eu des tours de passe passe pour nous
expliquer mais non on va prendre ici on
va donner là mais au final je pense que
notre peuple a bien compris et donc ça
fait au profit nahla l'arrivée un pays
sens dessus dessous
une question sur le rythme du travail
législatif pierre dharréville les
réformes elles se sont enchaînés dans un
premier temps mais depuis le début de la
crise des gels et jaune
la machine ne s'est elle pas enrayée on
a un gouvernement qui a voulu nous faire
légiférer à marche forcée or je pense
que nous avons un rôle important dans
cette démocratie qui doit être un rôle
pleinement lien avec ce qui se passe
dans les territoires avec les mouvements
qui peuvent émerger de mener le débat de
mener la discussion de prendre des
décisions qui soient les plus éclairés
possible par une expérience du réel etc
et le gouvernement a voulu embouteillée
et puis effectivement légiférer à tour
de bras mais il voulait beaucoup plus
compliqué de légiférer à notre place
elle revient deux fois at il légiférer
par ordonnance c'est à dire nous privant
de notre pouvoir de parlementaires donc
et je pense qu'il n'a pas eu ce
qu'emmanuel maquis n'a pas affaibli le
parlement ah oui cornac
c'est une il ya une volonté de se passer
egis l'acteur le plus possible du
parlement et de et de son action dans la
manière que cas mais emmanuel macron de
pratiquer de pouvoir il ya une pratique
assez solitaire finalement du pouvoir il
rend des comptes lui-même et la grande
palabres macro nien se poursuit et se
continue donc voilà effectivement la
machine s'est enrayée à force de vouloir
procéder de la sorte mais je crois que
cette volonté n'a pas disparu est-ce que
vous pensez que la crise des gilet jaune
1 va faire changer la façon de gouverner
d' emmanuel macron je crois qu'elle le
devrait très vite parce qu'il nous reste
dix secondes elle le devrait mais pour
l'instant je n'ai pas vu les signes
merci beaucoup pierre dharréville
d'avoir été l'invité de parlement hebdo
et nous on se retrouve très vite sur nos
antennes merci beaucoup aux katia très
bonne suite des programmes
[Musique]